[Music]
how are you
i'm so good how are you i like all your
your backdrop
yeah well you know i haven't been to a
concert in a while so i gotta keep my
music love somewhere i love him
well i had so much fun with this movie i
mean what better time to watch a
christmas movie than at the holidays too
when the opportunity to be
a part of the next installment in this
homeland franchise came your way what
was your reaction had you seen the
original film were you curious about
what this could be like what did you
think
i am definitely one of those people that
grew up on these movies i've probably
seen both of the movies over 50 times to
be honest like i'm a real big uh home
alone 2 fan when they go to new york
it's just it's so much fun so certainly
when i got the audition i was very
curious as to what they were going to do
because you know i'm one of those
original fans as well and five pages in
i was just i was sold i i was instantly
like okay i get what they're doing this
is such a fun and hilarious reimagining
it's not what anyone would think i think
uh which is super fun too of you know
having those easter eggs but then having
a lot of new stuff too that's coming in
so i just think the writers uh mikey day
sri sadel just really nailed it in tone
and and are creating a new story that is
gonna be fun for everybody
yeah i love that there was no point when
i was sitting there going like i i want
the other kid back you know like from
the original like i wasn't thinking
about right
i love that you know i was so invested
in this family and this kid and it just
i think that's a good sign it is a good
thing and like how charming is archie i
i just
i'd be on set and in between takes you'd
be like all right
how do you feel about this ally and it's
just like talking to a little grown-up
and then they'd be like action and he
would do something that was just so
tender and would make me cry and i'm
just like this kid is amazing like what
this is a character the character you
play is someone who's on the outer
circle of everything that's going on in
this family
she's not a relative she's not a villain
she's not trying to break into this
house
so because of that it seems like you
could have a lot of freedom with a role
like this
so was that the case was this a
character that you felt you could
develop a bit and add things to more
than just what was on the page
absolutely and from day one you know dan
mazer is so such an awesome director i
think him coming from you know doing all
the borat and the ali g stuff just made
he's so
incredible about giving us that license
to come up with a back story you know
come up with takes that we want to do
and sometimes he would let timothy and i
or tim and i go on for just minutes and
minutes of just whatever we wanted to do
there was some stuff i feel like we
could have our own extended cut of just
the antics that tim and i would do on
the side um and and that was just so
much fun i learned so much on that set
also just being surrounded by such
comedic people um and we just yeah we
just had such a great time
she also seems like the kind of
character that you know it would be easy
to sort of write off or not have to put
too much thought into because she is not
you know the kid or the couple trying to
break in but on the flip side it seems
like there could be extra challenges in
something like that to make the
characters still be interesting so that
she doesn't
fade into the background so is a
character like this more challenging
than people expect because you do you
still want to put your mark on her and
have her still be a part of the story i
think i was just so excited to be a part
of it and again like dan was just so
you know amazing about saying he wanted
every character to live and breathe as
their own thing so we talked a lot about
backstory and you know tim dan and i all
came up with this thing where you know
back in la you know she was a singer
like a failed singer and that's kind of
organically how this song came about you
know it was all not originally part of
the movie but you know he was just so
great about like well what do you guys
want to bring to it and from day one he
always said like i want you guys to be
able to like even if you're in a scene
and you you are just there like i want
you to be able to bring whatever
may would bring to the to that scene so
i think that was a a lot of the fun is
just being able to play it almost
sometimes felt like live theater as
opposed to like doing your traditional
kind of movie takes which i was so so
fun
did you also get to have a say in her
look her appearance or wardrobe any of
that did you help figure out what her
style would be
well our amazing costume designer
you know had such a vision but on that
first uh fitting we really did because
may you know it could go a certain
number of ways and because we've never
met before that first day we had so much
fun like maybe we do this and this you
know maybe we go super crazy and i think
where we landed was having you know the
chic black elements with some sort of
like crazy outerwear piece and that was
like always her thing so we you know we
it was a bit of a collaboration but she
definitely brought all of the crazy
pieces which was was so much fun
how do you think she feels about being a
part of this family
when she sees the relationship that jeff
and pam have i mean how do you think she
feels about this family that she's found
herself in
i think she's obsessed with all of them
like i think she's like low-key obsessed
with pam she's obsessed with uh you know
rob's character she's uh and obviously i
think she's a great aunt you know she's
a little bit out of touch because she's
from la and she's coming in with all of
her you know frills but at the end of
the day she's she's such a loving aunt
and i think that's also what we wanted
to show was that even if she is a little
bit out there that she still has a great
heart and that she's a great aunt and
i'm an aunt in real life too so i had so
much fun kind of bringing that that vibe
to the role too
as the writer of the original characters
john hughes was responsible for the home
alone franchise so
as an actor what does the legacy of john
hughes and his movies mean to you do you
have a favorite john hughes movie
oh my gosh i mean yeah what he created
is just iconic and it's it's awesome to
see how much he shaped all of our
childhoods and continues to shape you
know it's it's cool all yeah yeah right
it's like everyone i talked to is like
literally these movies shaped our
childhood um and even i think kids today
are still watching the classics and
hopefully they'll watch this one too and
it'll be just a great new addition to
the series and um but yeah i would say
it's got to be
home alone i mean is my favorite movie
of his like hands down
do you know what's next for you are you
currently working on something now are
you trying to figure out what you're
doing next
yeah a little bit of everything i
actually have um an animated series
that's coming out on the 17th marvel's
hit monkey which i'm also so excited
about we recorded some of that during
the pandemic and now it's it's coming
out and uh it's about a uh monkey hit
man named hit monkey
and he makes his way through tokyo and i
get to play detective haruka in that and
you know she's like a badass woman on
the force and um i had so much fun with
that too so yeah really looking forward
to this coming out and and marvel's hip
monkey
what does it mean to you to get to be a
part of the whole disney and marvel
family i mean you're sort of dipping
your toe in all things differently
it's so true i know i just feel very
lucky because my earliest memories are
just of me dressing up as jasmine and
singing disney songs all day so i just
feel like
i'm just that same girl that's in my
living room you know singing disney
songs and it's just i feel like what an
honor it is to be able to do this for a
living and to bring these stories to
life in whatever way i can and i mean
truly a dream i'm just always like what
what world am i living in where i get to
be part of not one cool disney you know
universe but a couple of them and and
that's just something i'll always uh be
grateful for
well i i love this character i love that
you were in this movie i would totally
love to see her have her own like disney
plush show because i just feel like it
would be so fun to see what she does
when you don't see her in this movie
so yeah
that would be her as a mother like yeah
i want more of that like what is that
world
she just seems like such a fun character
with the life that i i wanted to know so
much more about ah i love that thank you
so much well you never know and this in
these times with disney plus and all the
streaming
well thank you so much for talking about
her
awesome so nice to meet you
you